[Musica]
Anita, che cos'era?
Hey...
[Musica]
ma che è questo odore di pesce
oh! Vitale!
[nuota sott'acqua]
e che cos'è quello? uno squalo? un pescecane?
Uno squalo tigre? Anita! Vengo a salvarti!
Vengo a salvarti dallo "squelo"
Anita, cosa ti è successo? ti ha mangiato lo squalo?
aiuto! devo fare qualcosa, mi è venuta un'idea
aspetta lì
lasciala, lasciala ho detto, guarda che te lo tiro un colpo di scopa!
Anita, vengo io a salvarti
Sono io Vitale! cos'è questo?
è la mia coda! Cosa? Come la tua coda?! è la mia coda da sirena!
Ti ha mangiato?! NO! non è nessun pescecane non è
nessuno squalo! e che cos'è? ..ho trovato
questa nel fondo della piscina
l'ho indossata e mi ha trasformato in
una sirena... ma ci penso io la tolgo io
questa coda da sirena! NO, non si può togliere!
No, ora usciamo fuori dall'acqua così
ti faccio vedere bene la coda da
sirena. Ok ti aiuto io
Ma come hai fatto a trasformarti in sirena
te l'ho detto ho trovato questo ciondolo
nel fondo della piscina
l'ho preso e l'ho indossato e mi ha
trasformato in una sirena.. ma hai provato a
toglierlo
magari ti ritornano le gambe normali
proviamo ....ehhhh trasformazione
ma non succede niente? no non funziona
come faccio?! non posso vivere con la
coda da sirena non potrò mai più
camminare
aspetta aspetta aspetta lasciami
pensare un attimo
devo spremere il mio cervelletto.... no
niente.... ho la soluzione
tu resta qui, non andare da nessuna
parte, aspettami che ritorno ok?
arrivo subito
[Musica]
città, uccelli, pesci, sirene...
ecco cosa devo fare!.... acqua calda in
padella, sale, tagliato in cubetti e
perfetto! ci sono!
[Musica]
avevo l'acqua sul fuoco....
Ho un'altra soluzione! ho un'altra soluzione.... che cos'è?? ..è sale da cucina
ma perché?? ho letto sul libro che con il
pesce ci vuole il sale.... aspetta, aspetta, ho un ultima
soluzione.. BASTA... l'ultima l'ultima te lo prometto..
ultima l'ultima
[Musica]
Fermo, fermo, fermo! cosa vuoi fare?
Tagliare la coda così ti crescono le gambe!
NO, BASTA! si si .... ti ricrescono!!! ....basta non
voglio più saperne delle tue soluzioni
riportami in acqua! ok, va bene qui?
sì grazie
lasciami un momento da sola ok
[Musica]
ci sono! dobbiamo andare al mare..! perché
dobbiamo andare al mare? ...ho sentito il
rumore del mare nella conchiglia e
quindi forse vuol dire che ci sta
chiedendo di portarla al mare cioè di
riportarla al mare..... ottima idea!!
finisco le patatine e andiamo subito!
Ma, Anita... sei sicura che al mare troveremo la
risposta? mah... io spero proprio di sì
tutt'al più ci mangeremo un gelato......
[Musica]
ti aspetto qua allora...
ciao Anita, finalmente sei arrivata
[Musica]
ti sarai resa conto che non è facile
essere una sirena.... così come non è facile
per noi, abitanti del mare, vivere nel
nostro ambiente
[Musica]
io posso farti tornare come prima
dobbiamo solo aggiustare le cose... dare al
mare ciò che è del mare... e riprenderti ciò
che appartiene a voi essere umani.... e
ricorda non esitare a tornare per
aiutarci a pulire il mare!
[Musica]
Ciao Pagurino, CIAO
Anita!!
ce l'ho fatta sono di nuovo un essere umano!
Ho le gambe! Ma come hai fatto?
dovevo riportare al mare ciò che è del
mare
e riprendere dal mare ciò che appartiene a
noi esseri umani!! ....ma che bello!!! finalmente
adesso possiamo andare a prendere un
gelato
andiamo dai
[Musica]
cos'è che mi ha toccato? un polpo? ....è questo
che cos'è????  Vitale.....
Oh NOOOOOOOOOOO